[Music]
the PC revolution started this computing
world that we live in today the internet
came and connected the pcs together
more recently mobile has made computing
everywhere we go ai is well poised to
revolutionize yes revolutionize yet
again how we compute how we connect and
where we do all these things and make it
ubiquitous my name is Yu Feng and I'm a
developer advocate at Google today I
want to convince you guys that combining
the power of mobile and artificial
intelligence and machine learning will
make your systems and change the world
that we live in today for the better and
make for great experiences since 2000
half of the fortune 500 have disappeared
only a few short years ago startups and
companies were only occasionally
mentioned artificial intelligence as
this extra add-on to their business
process or to this idea they had but now
virtually every startup is an AI startup
they just got a tag that on the end
right here at Google we've incorporated
AI and machine learning into many of our
mobile experiences and hopefully you
recognize some of these on the screen
and hopefully you've found them to be
enjoyable for doing machine learning on
mobile we still train on the server and
classically we think of training machine
learning models has a very compute
intensive action right how can we do
machine learning on mobile mobile
devices are lower powered they can't
flex ow - many many virtual machines
so what I want to discuss is the model
where we still do the training on the
server but we're going to do the
prediction our device and you can get
away with still using mobile to call out
to your server for prediction and just
like a web app or a website but if you
put your actual prediction put your
machine learning model on the physical
device itself it can lead to some
amazing user experiences a great example
that I like to call out is Google
Translate it uses onboard machine
learning to overlay the translated text
this couldn't be done if it was
transferring basically the video of what
is being held from the screen over the
network sometimes you might be in
another country and you don't have data
connection furthermore even if you had
data connection you would want that
immersive and responsive experience
maybe you're on a ship or on a plane
where there's no network connectivity
certainly you want don't want to be
streaming images over your satellite
phone connection but machine learning
it's kind of hard right and making
mobile apps that's no easy feat either
combine the two well that's a real
challenge so how can we make this easier
today I want to walk through a
particular paradigm that you can use to
do custom image classification so
recognizing whatever it is that you want
your mobile app to recognize using a
model that will live on the device so
let's take a look at what we're going to
build today so over here I have my phone
I've got it casting via chromecast so if
we switch over to the demo and so what
we have here is a camera basically and
we've got some candy here you might
recognize some of these from earlier
in the conference some of you might have
enjoyed some of these peanut butter cups
these are the milk chocolate ones and
over here we have the white chocolate
peanut butter cups and you can see it
switching over eventually and then over
here we have some just traditional
Reese's peanut butter cups and you can
see that you know I can move it around
and the confidence at the top is
remarkably high and I've actually got a
smaller Reese's Cup here so we got
Reese's small and a Reese's large so
that'll switch over and then just for a
variety we got a pack of juicy fruit
here just so you know for the people who
are allergic to peanuts and this of
course all works in airplane mode so
we're in oh right of course it's not
going to work in airplane mode and
chromecast so switching back to the
slides let's talk about how we can build
such a system and do it with a way that
doesn't involve tedious data collection
and labeling and then spending weeks of
training on a big server with GPUs and
writing distributed code and then we
haven't even talked about how we're
going to package that up for mobile
right as you can see I use smash from
the conference I didn't know what snacks
they were going to have I made this this
week it took less than an hour and sure
I did some preparation so that I would
be ready when I got here but there's no
big system running on the background
making this happen so what does it look
like to go from training tap the first
step is gathering your training data and
in this case we're going to do it with
video and sometimes the video doesn't
like to cooperate so I have it whoops go
dark
I have it here so what I'm doing is
literally taking a video of what it is I
want to use a training because what is
the video after all but tons and tons of
images being captured really quickly so
if we take this video and split it out
into its frames we end up with lots of
training data and since they're all
batch together one video is one folder
full of images to train with so I just
use ffmpeg literally a command line tool
just copy paste icon landline in replace
the file name and put it in the folder
name the folder in this case Justins
milk-chocolate and make another one for
trust ins white chocolate make one for
juicy fruit and you would you get you
get these pictures right no surprises
there next step is to upload them to the
clock we're going to do our training
using cloud machine learning engine and
store our pictures in google cloud
storage and that again is a solve
problem that is basically just running a
few commands to upload some files upload
some data and kick off the training and
then after the training is done well
we'll get to that let's talk more about
this training step right don't let me be
the one to gloss over the the hard work
of machine learning so we're going to do
a little sidebar because it's image
recognition and if you guys have
background in machine learning you know
that we're going to use convolutional
neural networks so that's a lot of
syllables and I never won the spelling
bee but I took me a while to understand
what convolution is and what machine
learning was doing to recognize images
so I want to use a little analogy of a
jigsaw puzzle I recently worked really
hard to solve and this is an MC Escher
painting but it's actually a box cover
of a jigsaw puzzle and usually when you
go to solve a jigsaw puzzle I'm no
jigsaw puzzle expert but maybe you guys
have some advanced techniques you can
share with me later but I first separate
the white pieces and everything else
right this this one was a real pain
because the edges were there's a lot of
white space and those pieces take
forever to put together so you separate
those out and you say well I know that
the white stuff is like that and then
the rest well that's a jumbled absolute
jigsaw puzzle is but wait the roof the
roofs that are in this painting are a
very distinctive pattern and so I can
use that to my advantage I can go and
find the pieces that look like this
pattern and boom I can piece that
together then I can say well these
stairs they got some of these parallel
lines going and the railings have these
X's on the banisters I can use that to
my advantage and find pieces that are of
that shape and then put that together so
what does this have to do with machine
learning a convolutional neural network
in the abstract can be thought of as
looking at for these detailed patterns
in the same way that your eyes can it's
looking at these sub patterns and then
piecing them together to come to
conclusions about the bigger picture to
piece these X's and the lines of the
stairs to say well there's a staircase
there or there's a roof there and
piecing together the roof and the stair
and the hallway and the clock tower you
get the conclusion that you have an MC
Escher painting now I said there are a
lot of white pieces here and so it took
me a really long time to even get to
this stage so this is this is as far as
I got because the other white pieces
were just not cooperating so moving on
from that analogy let's talk about the
actual thing I use to train it and it's
using what's called the inception v3
model this is a convolutional neural
network that Google used to win the
imagenet competition a few years back
that's a International machine learning
image classification competition and it
is forty eight layers peep to give a
little context about what 48 layers
is and how significantly large that is
as recently as 2011 it was Impractical
to train a neural network that was more
than four layers deep so this was a huge
leap the biggest networks the year
before this network one image net was 22
layers so it more than doubled the size
and ran through the whole thing and
could classify a thousand different
images and so we're going to repurpose
that we're going to take all of the
advancements that were used to make this
possible to classify our candy so what
we can do is we take that last layer of
the network and we're just going to
train that part that last step is what
separates out into buckets if you will
the different classes that are being
recognized so in this case our five
classes the two different Reese's Cups
the milk chocolate the white chocolate
peanut butter cups and our Jersey fruit
so we feed in our input data at the top
you see the Reese's Cup at the top and
we make the values in that neural
network all the same they're not all the
same all frozen we don't let it Train we
don't let it move we only let that last
layer be trained so those values get
updated during the training and
everything else stays the same in this
step of it this core piece of it is a
pretty well understood step now this
retraining aspect and in fact we have a
code lab I would send you downstairs to
do it but this is the last session right
but it is online so you can do this for
your own problems as well and now moving
on from that I want to focus on what we
do to go from a trained model to a
trained model on Android because if you
come at this from the naive approach and
say okay I got the model let me put it
on Android it will not work at all
because the libraries that are used on
the Android version of tensorflow
are missing certain operations
certain operations because you don't
want to do training on mobile as we
talked about before
not much compute power so we need to
strip down the model and that is nice
because the output of this training is
84 megabytes which is it's a real
whopper so we want to size that down a
little right we and we're going to
optimize it for mobile so let's talk
about this down sizing there's a
command-line tool called the graph
transform tool and what it does is if
quantizes the model what is quantization
what it means is that does the model
which is just a file filled with
floating point numbers decimals and
these floating point numbers are
typically 32-bit so reasonably high
precision and reasonably base ticking so
we're going to downsize it we're going
to downsize it to 8 bits we're going to
make all the values 8 bits but when that
affects the accuracy fair question
thankfully neural networks are designed
to be tolerant of fuzzy inputs is
designed for a little leniency and still
be accurate so you can get a 4x savings
in size with only a marginal falling off
in the error which is great because now
we have a 20 megabytes model that we can
add to our app one additional
consideration how we add the model to
our app is up to you you can put the
model in the app itself so that when
your users download the app from the
Play Store they will have the model
built in and that means your app will be
say 20 megabytes bigger so you could
also put the model alongside your app as
a file then when they download the app
they won't have that exercise but you
have other considerations right you need
to then have logic in your app to
download that model on your own at some
point
maybe you only do it over Wi-Fi what
about other advantages and disadvantages
perhaps you say well I really want to
keep my model secure I'm afraid that
people are going to look at these
floating-point numbers in this file and
divine some kind of conclusion about it
so I want to keep it secure and packaged
in my app so you might go with the first
option or maybe you say I want the
flexibility of being able to update my
model whenever I want maybe you just
push down the dip and not update the app
itself so then you say ok I'll put the
model as a separate file and then I can
have logic in my app to do these updates
so this is a set of trade-offs that you
have to weigh for yourself in my case I
packaged it with the app partially
because it was more straightforward to
just deploy the whole thing to my phone
and so yeah so that's what we saw today
we packaged it up we put it into the app
and that's kind of our full training
pipeline from training to app or from in
the arcades video to app turning that
video into pictures training it in the
cloud
and then pulling down that train this
model and optimizing it for mobile and
then loading it into an Android app and
so you're pretty much ready to ship it
so at this point I want to step back
zoom out a little bit and talk about
what makes all this possible because
it's only been in recent year let's say
that tensorflow
a has existed it's only been around for
say 15 ish months and before that how
would you have done machine learning on
mobile how long would that have taken
you collecting the training data where
would you have trained it what would you
use to train it how would you deal with
the size of that apk right without
having abilities to prune down the size
of the model and you would have to build
your own framework for loading that
machine learning model into the device
itself so the reality is what you would
probably end up doing is hosting a
prediction service in the cloud on your
servers and having that molded with
mobile device call out to that endpoint
with
arrest API and doing that you incur all
the kind of detractions that we kind of
talked about earlier wherein you can't
have these immersive experiences where
you can't point a camera at something
and instantly have it show what it is
so tensorflow has really changed scheme
there and what's really great is that
not only does it work for what i've
shown you today with android but it is
also equivalent on iOS and raspberry pi
so you can deploy your mobile app across
all their favorite platforms another
reason that tensorflow has been
fantastic both for me and for all of you
is the community so many people are
making examples with tensorflow creating
really cool use cases answering each
other's questions and supporting and
helping each other grow and build great
experiences and that's only in the most
recent year and change and now that
tensorflow is 1.0 as of mid-february
you can use it with confidence in
production knowing that the API will not
change under you until potential flow
2.0 which is so far down the road that I
haven't even give another thought until
just now so machine learning on mobile
leads to awesome experiences you can do
it now without having to you utilize the
the pains of the past and tooling has
gone to a point where you can
essentially follow a recipe and have it
work and moreover to be able to do it
for your specific application is what
makes it really powerful because you
could certainly load up inception that
network with its pre training system
that can recognize a thousand different
things but they're just kind of random
things boats and oranges and trees and
houses and streets and sidewalks
you care about specific things right you
want to build an app that can recognize
your things so being able to retrain it
and being able to retrain it with ease
with captioning video without having to
amass terabytes of data and spend weeks
of time to load process and train up a
model and then still have to make two
consideration about mobile makes this
quite awesome and so feel free to come
up at the end we can play with the the
app that I made but that's really a toy
example you saw the way I was capturing
that video I was just kind of walking
around taking the video trying to do it
on a white background because I knew the
podium would be white but in your real
case example real-world example you
would perhaps do it with a variety of
backgrounds maybe in shade and in
sunlight
maybe on white surfaces on carpet on
wood on metal think about where your
users might see the things that you want
to recognize so that's kind of the whole
process as a training pipeline and it
allows you to think of it as something
that you don't have to have a huge
burden on anymore you can basically pour
the data in at the top and then have
machine learning in an app coming out
the other side it's no longer a problem
where you say well let's see if we're
going to make this work we might need to
hire a team of PhDs to think about how
we can recognize our specific product
they're very subtle some of them are
only a little bit different from the
others inception can take care of that
the model itself notices the most minut
differences and hopefully many if not
all of you have had a chance to wander a
little bit about around the third floor
is that during the conference where we
have the example with the candy sorter
which is based on a Japanese farmer who
built basically this system
but on a Raspberry Pi to sort his
cucumbers and I don't know about you but
I can't tell the difference between
cucumbers they all kind of look the same
even at the store there's like normal
cucumbers and then they have the fancy
ones that are called like European
cucumbers and there's like longer and
thin but they're all packaged in plastic
so I never know whether or not they're
more fresh or less fresh and in Japan
there's tons of different types of
cucumbers and this guy's growing them
all together and before he had to
categorize these all himself because you
sell them to different places right and
now he has a system that does it for him
and in that situation you have a very
controlled environment he knows the
cucumbers will come down this conveyer
belt he's got the camera and he will see
it in this orientation in my situation I
knew that I would be pointing my camera
at the podium at an angle with a white
background under bright lights so when I
trained my model I found a white table
with bright lights and pointed my camera
in my video at my objects I walked
around in a circle to cover the angles
but I didn't do much else because I
didn't need to so you can solve kind of
a whole range of problems depending on
your particular use case and so thinking
through this problem in in this model in
this mode where and you don't
necessarily have to completely start
from scratch but just thinking about a
few key points can help with the design
consideration so to speak and save a lot
of trouble down the road
and so I mentioned that there is a way
to retrain this or do this online right
because the conferences add a closed and
so I have a short link for you there you
can do this online that will guide you
through the process of retraining the
network so then you just have something
on your computer that does this and for
the mobile side of things if you go over
to tensorflow org slash
mobile it will point you to the Android
the iOS and the Raspberry Pi github
examples that you can literally clone
build and employ straight up
no code changes and then once you have
that working you can connect the two
together you can take the transfer
learning that inception that first code
lab take the output of that run the
graph transform tool and then replace
the graph that was in your Android
assets folder with that one and then
finally it has the cloud machine
learning resource there to learn more
about that and how to get at that part
working though the code that's the top
does talk about that so with that I want
to thank you guys
[Music]
you
[Music]